this is tomoh hussein reading for
reviewer mark delaney a dusty motel in
the middle of nowhere doesn't sound like
a typical video game setting but debut
studio interior knight uses this
peculiar place to create a game unlike
anything else you'll play this year as
thus fall definitely explores themes of
inherited hardship through the lens of
two families who cross paths on one
pivotal night by way of incredible voice
acting a compelling and expertly written
script and a bounty of pause-worthy
choices along the game's elaborate
branching pass it establishes itself as
an instant classic in the narrative
adventure genre dale
what are you doing it's called
controlling the room by pointing guns at
puppies
i wasn't breaking the casting boy's jaw
enough for you don't you start with me
or what you'll break my face too or
you're just gonna shoot me
playing as dusk falls reminded me of
something i think about a lot how each
of us is just the end result of every
moment we've experienced before today we
often like to make up reasons for why we
do something drive recklessly win the
spelling bee get a divorce give an
unhoused person some money but
ultimately our behavior is more
determined by our past than what we feel
like our split second choices in the
moment rationalization comes after the
act as a way to make sense of ourselves
enough bad experiences especially at an
early age can create fundamentally
flawed people who routinely make poor
choices while a rosier upbringing can
birth inspiring role models to some
extent we're fated for success or
failure before we even know we're on the
playing field as dusk falls swims in
these complicated wars jay
what head out of the clouds little bro
knew he shouldn't have brought him come
on he'll pull his weight the game opens
in 1998 when two families collide
literally on a desert road in arizona
the walkers are moving cross-country to
reset their lives after the patriarch of
the family vince was let go from his job
as an airplane mechanic due to a
controversy that might end in litigation
the halts meanwhile are infamous locals
that have been making noise in the
otherwise quiet town of two rock for
decades sideswiped by the halts who flee
the scene the walkers seek salvation at
the desert dream motel the closest sign
of life in the desolate world before
long the halts end up there themselves
following a robbery that goes south and
in their desperation the halts take the
walkers and others as
hostages on the ground now
i said get on the ground right away
interior night showcases a keen
understanding of pacing and exposition
you'll quickly understand each
character's place in the story and what
kind of energy they bring to it but
that's not to say they are predictable
and one-sided as dusk force focuses on
these two families and several other
characters who get caught up in the mess
and every single one of them is made
interesting and dynamic because this is
a choose your own adventure style game
in the vein of those from telltale's
supermassive aquatic dream you'll
steward each of these fascinating
characters through the use of frequent
dialogue options and quicktime events
[Music]
the game's motion comic style means you
aren't exploring the world in first or
third person which helps keeps the story
moving at a pace that mimics a serial
drama perfectly with smartly timed
flashbacks that flesh out characters and
cast so-called heroes or villains in new
lights paired with an audio experience
that fills in each scene the way you'd
expect to hear in an audio drama podcast
the characters managed to come to life
despite their still framed delivery
while a playlist of licensed music
further settles the story in a place
that feels real and lived in the police
are gonna catch you and
put you in jail you cut it out or i'll
put you in a corner hey
you can't talk to my granddaughter like
that she's six years old she's just
speaking her mind yeah i'm speaking my
mind enough this delivery also seems to
save as dusk falls from a major pitfall
of the genre without needing to animate
each character based on your dialogue
choices conversations flow much better
sometimes in games like this one you can
almost hear the cuts between voice lines
and presentation suffers as the game
jumps around reacting to this dialogue
branch or that one but that doesn't
happen in this game every conversation
expertly moves the plot forward and does
it without the video gamey stutter steps
or pacing problems that you might be
used to in such a game what
no no stop you listen to me
what i want is a helicopter or i start
killing hostages as if delivering a
best-in-class story wasn't enough as
thus fall also builds on the genre's
burgeoning social elements in a creative
manner it can be played in solo mode or
in a party as big as eight players each
of them casting votes to move the story
in their preferred direction this party
can be all local using up to four
controllers and a companion app it can
be all online between you and seven
others or it can be some combination of
local and online there's also a
broadcast mode so streamers can have
their say in the decisions in my
experience it worked as intended and the
added wrinkle of mixing in-person
players with online players seems like
the best use case of the game mode this
kind of game is made better when you can
argue over choices with your friends and
family and as dustful has a lot of
choices worth arguing over while so much
of asdas falls feels authentic its
depiction of police tactics comes off as
confusing at times in dealing with the
hostages situation the local two rock
police and other forces resort to
strategies that sometimes don't seem
sensible rather than a commentary on
something like the ineptitude of cops in
a crisis it feels more like an odd or
unresearched writing choice it was the
only moment in the game where i had to
suspend my disbelief though i hesitate
to be specific for fear of spoilers
[Music]
run for the door i'll cover you while
the game tells a complete and excellent
story it also leaves room for a sequel i
found its way of teasing that
possibility to actually hamper an
otherwise poignant finale causing an
emotional whiplash when i would have
been content to sit in the feelings the
game nearly chose to leave me with
ultimately the nuances of every
character and dialogue option are the
best part of as dusk 4's when you're
stuck on a decision screen it feels like
interior knight is always one step ahead
knowing that you can likely foresee how
any choice you make could save the day
or go south in a hurry
take zoey i'm uh
there's nothing wrong with me i don't
care who goes but only one of them
[Music]
as dusk falls can feel like it's the
same misery business as series like the
leftovers or six feet under meaning much
of the time your best laid plans will go
terribly awry partly due to its writer's
pension for melancholy but at the end of
the sixth and final episode a complete
story will come into view and it's one
that doesn't relish the idea of ruining
every character's life though i don't
doubt such an ending may exist somewhere
on the massive story tree visualized in
game rather it ends up telling a story
that brilliantly grapples with a lot of
underexplored or even unexplored themes
in video games like a lot of my favorite
games it left me with a lot to think
about such as the roles we choose or
reject the hardships we inescapably
inherit from family and how trauma casts
a dauntingly long shadow but how
forgiveness can let the light in you
boys are in way over your heads
you couldn't even nail a burglary now
you want a helicopter spare me the
lecture can you do it
i'll look into it
first i need a show of faith
let one of the hostages go i'm much of
one for faith all right
so let's make it practical
you must be hungry for a hot meal all
right how about we send you food you
release a hostage and then i start on
that helicopter
does that work pizza
enough from that shitty joining town
franco's veggie delight
give me 20 minutes
[Music]
good news folks one of you is going home
[Music]